a long-awaited who report on the origins
of covid19 has faced sharp criticism
worldwide some countries say the
investigation wasn't
extensive enough as many questions
remain unanswered
the who director-general himself called
for further studies after the report was
published
we got a first-hand account of the who
mission to wuhan
from a russian member of the team
our mission started off under phase one
why was it called that
it was clear from the beginning nobody
expected us to find answers to all the
questions right away
in fact it was proprietary work aimed at
analyzing the data we had accumulated
and establishing hypotheses
in general it's hard to predict how long
this investigation will take
and how it will end but it should be
done that's for sure
we've managed to find out that the virus
supposedly emerged in the period between
the middle of november and the beginning
of december
however we don't know the exact location
of the outbreak
in my view it was in china but it's not
clear yet
it's unlikely though that the outbreak
occurred in a wet market
most probably it was some market visitor
who had already been infected and
spread the virus this suggestion derives
from the fact that there were quite a
large number of patients who had nothing
to do with the market
we don't know who the first patient was
neither do we know the natural origin of
covid19
based on our common knowledge of various
coronaviruses we suggest that a bat
might have been a source
the issue is very much politicized
everyone is trying to find someone to
blame
i've never considered the lab league
hypothesis a theory
there's so much talk about this in the
media though but people don't really
have an idea
there is no scientific evidence or facts
proving a leak
as of today based on what we saw i can
say that the suspected laboratory is run
properly by well-trained staff
there is total compliance with all the
rules regarding work with viruses of
this hazard class or even the class
above
the laboratory is regularly audited and
is under constant scrutiny of competent
international organizations
building from that we therefore can't
say that a lab leak might have been the
cause
we didn't feel any pressure coming from
our chinese colleagues actually it
wouldn't even be the case i can't think
of how they could have put pressure on
us
we are in no way affiliated with china
people from various countries were part
of our team
who went to carry out this investigation
on behalf of the who
and what would have been the point of
pressurizing us we hardly liaised with
officials
we were largely in touch with scientists
you